what's going on there reject nation we
got john and we got koi zhandra with us
who just happened to be here we're
starting up a new segment called koi's
comic corner just shot two episodes for
it keep a lookout for the first episode
later on this week but we got our
she-hulk trailer surprisingly just
dropped out of nowhere and he just
happened to be here so very yay and
speaking of green characters i don't
think athletic greens are partnering up
with us this week because uh we're gonna
need some editor help for all the shows
we got coming out over the next couple
months but more about them after the
reaction of course in the meantime if
you guys can leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated subscribe click the
notification bell for everything else
we're going to be covering and follow
this man on tick tock and youtube enough
promo stuff let's do this
being a superhero
is a trial by fire
who's going to protect the world it's
not people like you
yeah
oh she looks awesome
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency um demanding
job we just started a super human law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
hit the trailer
you've got to deal with it he's got your
affirmations are triggered by anger and
fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
it feels like if i don't transform i'm
gonna die
it's jigsaw
yes yes
right now
oh my god you could be an avenger oh i'm
not a superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
oh man
get abomination right there
there's so much hulk in this is there
anything more depressing than dating in
your 30s
yeah this is the best that i've had in a
while
oh so should we split some fries let's
get those to go
the kinkside of marvel yes
that looks really funny that was a lot
of hulk that was a lot of hope though
let's just throw him in the teaser
trailer
my first thought was my mind started
going wasn't he back to normal bruce
banner in the shanghai post credits
last time we saw him as the hulk how
does this take place i was surprised
they even showed us like ambio blonsky
an abomination they showed hulk
abomination and shield fully transformed
in like a minute it looks like a really
delightful disney player and the budget
like hulk good hulk looked great
sometimes she hooked up that was like
three shots i was yeah yeah they're
curious about the tech they're using you
have to also increase her height a lot
she's very tall and that's kind of the
comedy i think you might be in that
place where it's like with bruce and
with mark ruffalo there's such a
transformation that you can see past the
uncanny valley whereas her the effect is
very close to her already you know
that's her work in physique yeah not
really changing
too much sure because yeah in that last
shot i was like sometimes i see it as a
person sometimes i see it as an effect
yeah and i noticed i would out loud be
like that looks cool because i think
other times it didn't and like
normally i'm just neutral but it said i
was like
yeah well i think it looks cool in the
sense of that you know like you're
really handing off the the hulk baton in
a lot of ways it still feels like a
she-hulk show and that hulk will be
supporting as opposed to tuning in only
for hulk yeah but we're gonna watch the
trailer again so this guy can gather
more thoughts or a little expert here
while we're doing that a word from our
sponsor thank you to athletic greens for
partnering up with us this month well
the schedule is wild as ours it's tough
to stay on top of proper diet and
nutrition luckily athletic greens eg1
formula makes your daily nutrition
simple delicious inconvenient get bigger
just one scoop contains 75 high quality
vitamins minerals probiotics and a whole
bunch more which supports gut health
nervous and immune systems energy focus
plus on a serious note ag-1 is lifestyle
friendly i'm actually allergic to dairy
so any shake i ever have has to be
dairy-free so whether you eat keto paleo
vegan dairy-free or gluten-free it's a
good fit plus it's completely natural no
harmful chemicals or gmos and for my
sake it helps improve my sleep quality
and mental clarity which is always a
boost it helps improve my gut health i
like to poop and i like saving money and
what's great about athletic greens is
your subscription only costs about three
dollars a day that's double what i paid
john and it comes with a year supply of
vitamin d and all that is way cheaper
than trying to get all these supplements
individually so head on over to
athleticgreens.com rejects to start your
ag-1 lifestyle today all right if we
didn't have to go to this movie premiere
for bob's big burger or whatever else
it's called
bob's big bird one of the biggest
series
of hamburgers we didn't have to go to
that we would uh take more time to break
this down because we want to do like
trailer breakdowns record i thought it
would focus a little bit more on the
actual legal side it seems to be dealing
a lot more with other qualities of like
stardom i'm curious by some of the
experimental sides that you saw hulk
looks like they're in tahiti or hawaii
or something of that nature he's like
set up a specific lab just for this
purpose which he does in the comic books
often there are times where he goes and
sets himself up remotely usually it's in
a desert like arizona but there have
been island times and i like that the
stark tech blades was a thing like he
might use stark tech to train himself or
her i actually like the i like that like
girl comedy stuff with like the the rich
housewives
girl
i don't know i think that shit's funny
for some reason
so i mean this doesn't feel like the
most steak heavy but it feels like a
really entertaining one i feel like what
this show's aiming for is mainly to be a
fun comedy one instead of a game changer
it looks light and it looks pleasant yet
you got big characters like hulk and
abomination in here
and i wonder if we're gonna get a
rematch with uh hulk and emil blonsky
which would be very fascinating johnny
yeah i thought this was very appealing
very uh fun it's a pretty solid approach
just to go with you were introducing you
to our main character and that's the
perspective of this trailer but it did
give me a couple things to look forward
to on the more stylistic side i mean
there are a couple of those shots that
have that like really red or blue tint
and just some of the ways in which they
were sort of visualizing her journey
looked really engaging and yeah i mean
the quick glimpses we got at what will
become the stakes like i was the one
person sitting around during daredevil
going i like the action stuff but i
really like the law stuff too let's do
more of that so i am excited to see this
become something that may be a little
lighter that may be designed for comedy
rather than having comedy sprinkled on
top of it and something that yeah gives
us a perspective switch and that
embodies a different type of movie you
know and koi we paused the frame for
some specific costume characters uh frog
is in this you believe that characters
frog i believe that's frog which is an
absurd character from the comic books he
is currently in the iron man comic book
which is like a weird team book because
he's so obscure they can just throw him
in without continuity issues he's
usually used as a punch line so i'd love
to see him used as a setup villain to be
like oh no can she fight frog and that's
it that's gonna be fun uh we also saw a
brief shot of titania uh who's played by
uh jamil jamil and i really think what's
gonna happen is we're gonna see the
evolution of her learning to not control
her powers but learn to control being a
public figure because it looks like like
you said the stardom stuff but we need
her to be so the focal point that when
she's in law it's distracting and i do
think that's where charlie cox comes in
charlie cox was at this presentation it
looks like according to twitter and i do
think charlie cox is gonna be part of
the show even though we didn't see him
here but i think it's gonna be fun
because he is a private lawyer with a
public persona she's a public persona as
a lawyer and i think there's going to be
some fun law stuff there because in the
comic books both charlie cox's daredevil
and her she-hulk do represent
superheroes and they briefly mentioned a
superhuman legal team that's being
assembled so i could see this turning
into maybe representing the things that
were happening in civil war as we get
towards characters like ms marvel coming
into play what you have legality wise
with teenagers and young avengers coming
into play i think it's really important
we establish a law expectation and then
you've got the superhero stuff with
abomination hulk to keep people
entertained this is a teaser i imagine
there's more action in this per capita
than what we're gonna get in the actual
show i do think we're gonna get like a
spin city kind of flavor and i think the
bigger it gets
it's been sitting but i think the bigger
it gets the more likely the fourth wall
break is coming i do think this is very
much john byrne meets charles soules
runs on she-hulk where the fourth wall
is broken where it's very self-aware and
i do think that allows us the bigger it
gets to get to deadpool and what do you
think about what's going on with emil
blonsky there so i think that we sauce
with chongqing last time we saw it was
strong chicken it was also kind of a
training place yeah i mean like i feel
like the dude is just used to get
punched like you're strong let's punch
him so i'm wondering if since he's been
able to be de-powered if that's a
conversation of how hulk is able to
control things how you know maybe he's
trying to cure the gamma radiation and
the way that she-hulk gets turned into
she-hulk is she shot and then the only
person that can help her is bruce banner
who does a blood transfusion and his
blood is obviously irradiated which
makes her she-hulk so i'm wondering if
there's some sort of element of blonsky
being him trying to cure his cousin
and then of course we have titania who
is our villain who i think is going to
be really interesting towards the legal
side of things what's it mean to be a
public hero what's it mean to have a
personal identity what's it mean because
if you notice the mcu most people don't
have secret identities like there's
pretty much just spider-man and
daredevil so i think those conversations
are going to come as we approach young
inventors i've been speaking very fast
because i know you've got bob's big boy
bird yeah
i gotta go to the restaurant yeah i know
people always tell me
the man's got boxing burgers
um but yeah no this is this is a great
trailer for the most part and uh keep a
lookout for koi's comic corner because
um that we're that we're all micked up
and we're taking our time to edit those
versus what you saw your day but thank
you athletic greens for sponsoring this
video and make sure to subscribe we'll
catch you guys soon